tennis fans will know who you've got
standing next to you there Bethany
well one of a big
pay is going to be accepting a Lifetime
Achievement Award and that's such a
great Accolade and very well deserved
but tell me first of all were you
shocked absolutely shocked I really
didn't expect it at all
um you sort of do your job and you just
don't really think it but you know
announcing retirement and and the
send-off I got at Wimbledon absolutely
amazed me and then to have this from
women in film and television is such an
important award and for them to
recognize what I've done means so much
to me and it's something I'll absolutely
treasure because
um you know it's uh it's been a
difficult journey in some ways but it's
been such a rewarding journey and I've
had two careers that I've Loved but my
broadcasting career particularly with
the BBC doing so many of the big
sporting events has just been a joy it's
I've loved it I never thought I'd find a
second career that I loved as much as my
first because I love my tennis but I did
working in broadcast for both those
areas like you said that you've worked
in sports then sports broadcasting both
are so male dominated aren't they
they're male worlds that is changing now
but tell me over your career you've
mentioned it with a difficult Journey
has there been moments when you feel
it's been much harder for you as a woman
to push forward and succeed well it
wasn't in tennis because when I started
in the 70s uh ancient history uh women
really weren't playing but of course at
that point the Magnificent Billie Jean
King arrived and suddenly won the Battle
of the Sexes got us a tournament got us
sponsors
I'll become my career so and I had 13
glorious Years playing tennis and then
when I quit tennis there was no women
doing sports uh presenting I tried to
get in as a pundit but there was no
vacancies but there was a wonderful man
at B Sky B came over to start B Sky B in
1989 David Hill was still a great friend
of mine today phoned me up and said sue
I want you to be a presenter I said
David I a I'm female and B I'm an ex
athlete I said you know that's a No-No
in in broadcast he said I want you to
and he encouraged me to go to the BBC so
without David I wouldn't have had that
step up to to even have the guts to go
for it but it was wonderful
you can make all the difference I've
just been so lucky as I said you know
Billie Jean King started my first grade
David Hill started my second you know
it's it's meeting the right people at
the right time and they they were they
were magnificent and and I I just feel
so privileged to have had the two
careers that I've had and also I know
you've been really vocal particularly a
few years ago when you moved on from a
question of sport about ageism in the
industry as a woman is that something
that's getting better up or still got a
lot of fighting to do close your ears
I'm 66 and the BBC offered me another
three years for Wimbledon so I have
really no argument with that the the
um question was brought there wasn't so
much about ageism it was more about just
the way it was handled because we accept
that we don't own the program and they
have the right to sort of move it on so
age ageism has never been a problem for
me but but you know but the BBC have
always been incredibly supportive as far
as as I said they offered me another
three years so I could have been going
on during Wimbledon until I was 70. but
you've got to know when the time is
right and the time is right and me this
year and 30 years of doing Wimbledon and
it was a perfect way to end very quickly
what next so what are you going to use
this Wimbledon time for I'm going to be
watching a lot of tennis I'm going to be
sitting in the stands watching tennis
and I'm also going to be doing a few
projects with Matt Dawson built up
Northern impression has fallen so yeah
not got rid of us quite yet reuniting
that's something to look forward to
scary well listen uh congratulations on
your award thank you and it's a
fantastic event I do treasure it it's
wonderful event absolutely well thanks
for talking to us I'm very glad to hear
that it all started with Skye exactly as
many good things to do but yesterday
we'll be continuing and you can check
back on our website to see all the
winners from the women in film and TV
Awards later today